We are joined now by the design guru of the Drew Crew,
and this show the one, the only Mikel Welch.
(audience applauds)
Aw, thank you.
Thank you.
At the desk!
I'm so excited to be here!
I mean, we are kicking off our happy place,
Mikel, design week.
Yes. We all love design week!
Right?
Please.
Do you mind if I just brag quickly
about your clients really quickly?
Oh gosh!
Tell me.
Let's see, Michelle Obama?
Right?
Yeah, I got a opportunity to do a project with her.
Uh huh. And who else, Mikel?
No, you said you were,
I'm gonna sound like I'm bragging if I say it,
but you know, Oprah.
(Drew screams)
Ah!
What?
Faith Hill.
You know? Just a few.
Oh my gosh and Mikel,
your talent is just unparalleled.
Your aesthetic, your taste, your knowledge
is so impeccable.
Thank you.
So I'm really excited to do some headlines
with you and get your opinion,
your experts eye, and ears, nose, and mouth
on a few subjects.
Let's do it!
All right, hit it.
Why don't you take this story Mikel.
All right, so here's a fun one, guys.
So in home design, everyone's familiar with the term
open concept, right?
That's that one wide, open interior space that has
lots of room, move and flow.
Well, guess what?
Martha Stewart, the queen,
she has said that there are reports that walls
are now coming back into style.
(audience groans)
Hm.
And she's saying that people are opting for
the sectioned off rooms now.
So this has kind of evolved from, you know,
all of us and our lives in the pandemic, right?
We're home a lot more, people are just like craving
that separate, defined space, you know?
Whether it's a different mode for working,
relaxing, zooming, et cetera.
But hey, that's what Martha said.
So let's see what we think.
I think it's interesting because
I've been reading so many design trends.
Like they're kind of coming outta the woodwork.
Absolutely.
It's amazing!
So I keep reading that separate rooms are now
much more on trend because people are working from home.
And they need the separation from their partners,
or family, or a designated area that sort of has that
energy and function.
And then when you switch rooms,
it's like you're in a different reality and space.
I mean, I really think it's this like,
you sit at home with your partner,
and now your kids have become like your co-workers,
it's a lot!
Like the kids are running around,
the dog, like it's a lot!
So it's like, can corral this and like get everyone
into a separate room, so that we can all think.
Like, we need that!
Really? No I like to do,
no, no, no.
I like an open concept, okay?
Because I like to do a lot at once.
Okay.
I'm doing laundry,
I'm cooking,
I'm watching 90 Day Fiancee,
and I'm doing it all in a big, one big space!
(audience applauds)
And I know that maybe that's like
aesthetically not the most beautiful,
but functionality wise, I get it done!
You wanna see it all!
Yes please!
I need, like get away from me for a second.
Like, I don't want to hear your Zoom call,
like I don't, listen, I listen, let me have my own space,
where I can just go, and I can think.
Oh you can have your space,
I'll be in the rest of the house!
Enjoy your little room!
(everyone laughs)
All right, well how about this.
Another big design trend blowing up Pinterest right now
is called dopamine decor.
And Metro reports, it's all about creating that interior
space that boosts your mood.
People are leaning into a ton of bold colors,
Drew, like you were saying, fun shapes, poppy wall papers.
Now are you seeing this kind of trend in design right now?
Not on my Instagram feed.
Ooh!
(audience laughs)
I will say this,
I think it works for the right person.
I think if you do it in doses,
it's something you can live with.
But that's a lot!
Like, that looks like a crayon box exploded!
Like I don't know if I can live like that everyday.
Listen, I've said before on the show
that I, my house is just white, you know?
Like I, I do need a little bit of this.
Because there is something,
You love a vanilla!
I, right!
I'm team vanilla too, honey. It's okay.
I like it.
But then when you go into a space,
well maybe you guys have done this.
When you walk to a restaurant or a bathroom
or something that's like,
there's a bold wallpaper.
I think, oh my god I would love to do this!
I just don't know how to do this.
I have an idea.
What?
What's that?
Well first of all, you could like start with a bathroom.
Okay!
Like a little powder room.
Or a smaller room.
Powder room.
What if we did something at Ross' house?
(audience applauds)
Oh! I love that.
Oh! And not tell him what it is?
No, no! We'll just,
Oh he'll have anxiety about it. (laughs)
Oh yeah, I'll have total anxiety, but I'm in!
I'm in! I mean, I'm nervous but I'm in.
I like that.
Okay. All right.
We want to take on a design challenge.
Watch this is all happening in real time right now.
We wanna like take on a room in your house that
you could pick what it is,
you could pick us a bathroom,
or like a sitting room, or whatever.
I love this!
Sitting room, I don't know what I'm talking about.
What do you think I live in? Like Downton Abbey?
(all laugh)
A sitting room.
As soon as I said it,
I realized what an idiot I was.
Okay!
Will you give Mikel and I the keys to your house?
(laughs)
Ah, you are hired! Yes you are!
Yeah! We got a job!
Guys! Yeah!
So Mikel,
Yes.
Before we go to commercial break,
what is one thing that you're really loving right now
as a top designer, that you could share with us?
Okay, I'm afraid.
You know, this is an aggressive audience.
I don't know.
But,
We like that.
I'm loving this new black trend with like matte black,
and people are painting like their kitchen counters,
their painting like their kitchen islands.
People are not afraid to us black now
as like an accent color.
And so that's a big trend that I'm loving!
Embracing it.
Also, another thing is just like embracing the nineties.
But the good nineties.
(audience agrees)
Like the proper forest green and like,
you're gonna see now like lots of archways.
And it's like the good part of the nineties
that we're bringing back.
(theme music)